a 16 year old died at Desert Oasis High
School this happened yesterday Clark
County School District says the students
suffered a medical issue while playing
sports Joshua peguero is live near
campus this afternoon with the story
Josh what's the latest
the Clark County coroner's office
identified the victim as a Shari huge
students and families were notified of
her passing this morning by the Desert
Oasis High School principal Ian Salzman
at this time the cause and manner of
death is still pending to be released
staff began performing immediately
Medical Aid yesterday and continued
until paramedics arrived according to
the principle Hughes was described as a
student athlete principal Salzman says
parents need to monitor their kids for
signs of grief or behavioral changes the
CCSD crisis response team will be
available for any students or staff who
need their services superintendent Dr
Jesus Jara also sent his condolences
saying the district is saddened by the
sudden loss and their thoughts are with
the family friends and loved ones of
Miss Hughes reporting live near Desert
Oasis High School Joshua peguero eight
news now Josh thank you very much you'll
certainly follow the story all through
the day ccsd's crisis response team is
available for students and staff at
Desert Oasis or anywhere else make sure
to remind your children there is someone
to talk to about their